Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar-winning actor
you know from movies like,
"Three Billboards Outside
Ebbing, Missouri," and "Vice."
He just received
a Tony nomination
for Best Leading Actor
in a play for his work
in "American Buffalo,"
which is playing on Broadway
at the
Circle in the Square Theatre.
Please welcome back to the show
Sam Rockwell, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-Hey, man. Good, man.
Really good. Hi.
-You know, I realize...
Obviously this is done
for a reason,
because Tony Award nominations
come out on a Monday.
-Yes.
-So all you guys are dark.
So you can actually celebrate
a little bit.
-That's right. That's right.
I had --
I had a couple of libations,
and then I got the call about
being on national TV tonight,
and I realized maybe I should
put that 17th one down.
And I was like,
"Okay. That's enough of that."
-Yeah.
-But I saw a movie yesterday
that was -- that I think
your producer was talking about.
-Yeah.
-"Everything Everywhere
at Once."
-Yes, which I've heard
is incredible.
-It's -- I think it's
the best movie this year.
I just flipped out, man.
I just thought --
I thought it was just amazing.
-And did you actually
go to the theater?
-I did.
-That's really exciting.
-With some friends. Yeah.
It was great.
It was really fun.
-Did you know in the morning --
Did you have any expectation
that the --
Were you, like,
going to pay attention
or were you going to wait
until somebody called you,
as far as the nomination?
-I kind of needed to sleep,
so I did that.
And then I got
a bunch of texts, yeah.
-Yeah. That's really exciting.
-It is exciting.
-And tonight, after this,
you're going to go
and you're going to do your
first show as a Tony nominee.
-Yes.
-A little extra pressure?
-A little extra pressure.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But it's really --
it's a really cool show.
It's a famous David Mamet play.
And you're doing it with Larry
Fishburne and Darren Criss.
-Yeah.
-Larry Fishburne, I mean,
one of the --
one of the all-time greats.
-Laurence Fishburne, I think,
one of the greatest
living actors
on the planet, really.
He's -- He's really something.
I mean, he's -- He and I,
you know, we FaceTimed
during the pandemic to --
The lines.
We would run lines and stuff
and gotten really close.
And the formidable Darren Criss,
who was on the "Versace."
-Yeah, he was fantastic.
-He did "Hedwig," you know.
He's -- He's amazing, and --
Yeah.
So it's -- I'm very lucky
to be working with these guys.
-Do you ever -- with someone
as iconic as Laurence Fishburne,
are you ever --
are you ever looking at him
and seeing other characters
he's played?
-I do. I do.
You'll see -- Just like
you would with
Christopher Walken or any of
these people, Gene Hackman,
you'll see a little
Popeye Doyle or something.
And, yeah, I mean,
you'll see a little Morpheus,
a little Ike Turner.
You'll see, like, that --
You see -- I think with
Chris Walken, same thing.
You had that experience
where you see "The Deer Hunter,"
you see "The Dead Zone."
And, you know, I think a lot
of people don't realize
that the reason
people like Chris and Laurence
are so amazing
and why they can, you know --
Chris Walken in "Pulp Fiction,"
he can do that monologue
or, you know, all of a sudden,
you know,
Laurence is -- is Morpheus.
I think they don't realize
all the stage they've done.
You know, Laurence won a Tony
for "Two Trains Running,"
and he's done "Fences"
and he's -- "Thurgood."
And so, like, that -- they bring
that to their film work.
-Yeah. They know exactly --
Yeah, they know how to connect.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's a really cool thing
to see.
You obviously have been
a big part of the New York
acting scene for a long time.
We were talking backstage.
-Yeah.
-This is one of my favorite
photographs of New York City.
-Oh, yeah, that's amazing.
-So this is --
And I asked you because
I never knew what it was.
This is you, Justin Theroux,
Philip Seymour Hoffman,
and Billy Crudup.
And I'm always like, "Why
are these guys in tracksuits
smoking cigarettes?"
Because it doesn't
quite look like --
-Smoking is really --
-Yeah.
-It really doesn't --
It was -- it was
a "Celebrity Charades."
It's a charity.
-So you were --
It was "Celebrity Charades"
and you dressed up in costume?
-Yes, and Yul Vazquez
was on that team
and he took that picture.
And we were the winning team
for two years in a row.
And it was "Celebrity Charades,"
if you could picture that.
Robin Williams did it. It was
very nice to do it for us.
And a lot of people --
Julia Roberts.
And, so, yeah, we're just
getting ready, warming up.
-Yeah, you're just walking.
You're just on your way to
go do "Celebrity Charades."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Oh, so that's --
-Phil did a "True West"
in the theater
I'm acting in now,
which is really great.
-We've talked in the past
about your parents were --
Your mom was an improviser,
Your dad was an actor.
And -- And, you know,
it must have been a unique
upbringing having parents
in the arts like this.
But what was Urban Pioneers?
-Mm!
Urban Pioneers -- Urban Pioneers
is kind of like Outward Bound.
It's like a kind of --
But for me, it was for all
the sort of dropouts,
you know, the people
who were getting D-minuses.
-Okay.
-And so they would send you
to this Outward Bound
kind of thing,
but it turned out to be
a really amazing program.
-So this is -- Do they sort of
take you aside at school
and they're like,
"Sam, this school is --
You're not crushing it.
So we're going to -- we're going
to send you to the woods."
-Yeah, exactly.
-And it was in the woods?
Was it actually?
-It was in the woods.
We did a hiking trip
for two weeks.
We would rappel
off mountains and stuff,
and it was really cool.
We learned how to --
-Were you hesitant at first?
-I was. I was.
Because all the dropouts
would go there.
But it turned out actually --
-Did all the dropouts come back
or did they leave a few...?
-They would come back.
-Okay.
-They would come back
more rugged.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And, you know,
it really, actually,
turned out to be life-changing.
-Really?
-And -- Yeah, Wayne McDonald
was the guy, and he --
he kind of changed my life.
I did a monologue for the class
from "The Hustler,"
and it really kind of changed
my whole direction.
And one of the big things
is that when we went
on the hiking trips,
we had to solicit food
from places like Pizza Hut.
You have to get like five cans
of tomato sauce.
-You would just walk into
a Pizza Hut and say,
"We're going on a hike.
We need tomato sauce"?
-Exactly.
-Wow.
-You're, like, a teenager.
And you'd go into these places,
you know -- Straw Hat Pizza.
-And also, like, I mean, one of
the teenagers that looks like
maybe they're not
telling the truth, right?
-Exactly.
-I mean, it's the dropouts,
right?
-Exactly. A little shady.
And, you know, you want like,
you know, a case of margarine
and tomato sauce
for your hiking trip --
your two-week hiking trip.
And they're like, "Okay, uh..."
And -- But you couldn't ask
your parents to pay for it.
You had to go out
and solicit it
and ask them to give it to you,
and that showed some initiative.
If you wanted to eat on a trip,
you had to solicit this food.
And so that taught us
a lot about, you know, hustling
and, you know, auditioning
and that kind of stuff.
-Yeah, that --
Actually, as an actor,
it's a good idea to remember.
I mean, with that said,
I don't know if I was on a hike
I'd be psyched to eat, like,
a big thing of Pizza Hut butter.
[ Laughter ]
We got a big, like, industrial
hunk of Pizza Hut margarine.
-Yeah, there were some
other things and -- Yeah.
It was -
Yeah, you do the best you can.
-You do the best you can.
Well, obviously --
obviously, it paid off.
Whatever confidence it gave you
paid off.
And now, you know, obviously
you've done a lot of film work.
-Yeah.
-But being back in a theater,
especially an intimate space
like that,
how is it for you to be able
to see their faces --
to get that
instantaneous response?
-It's amazing, you know, and --
And, you know, people they have
their masks on and stuff,
but it's really --
it's really amazing.
And you could see them
if they're napping
or if they had
their iPhones out.
And Darren sort of gave them
a hard time at this --
when we asked for some money
for Broadway Cares.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, it's -- it's funny.
It's funny to see people
out there.
-Has a -- Have you had a phone
go off of somebody --
-We did.
-Okay.
-And Laurence maybe made them
poop their pants a little bit
by saying, "Don't do that."
And I think --
-Oh, in the middle of --
He broke -- He broke out of --
-A woman went like this.
And he said -- And I thought
he was going up on his lines,
you know,
and I saw him on stage.
And I -- I started saying my
line, and he wasn't responding.
And I saw him looking out
at the house, and I realized --
And then he went,
"don't do that again."
And then the woman didn't.
And then we were
going to complain to her,
and she beat us
and complained to us
about ruining her experience.
-Really?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I think the word --
I know, right? It's amazing.
-Yeah.
-I think the word "monster"
was used
and that Laurence had ruined
her theatrical experience.
And -- Wow. I mean, you know.
-Yeah.
-It's something.
-I do think we live in an era
where the first defense
ass [bleep] use is, like,
"You're the ass [bleep]!"
-Yes, yes.
-And I'm really worried
about it,
because I feel like
that's the move these days,
and I don't like it.
-I don't like it either, man.
But I'll tell you what, if --
if Laurie Metcalf
or Laurence Fishburne
told me to put my phone down,
I'd -- I'd do it.
-I'd, like, put it down
and never pick it up again.
-Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
-Alright.
Well, we're decent human beings.
I think if there's anything
to take away from this.
-I mean, I would hope so.
We're not at the movies.
-Hey, congratulations, again.
-Hey, man, thanks a lot.
-Thank you for being here.
You guys, Sam Rockwell.
"American Buffalo,"
now playing at the Circle
in the Square Theatre.